♪ ♪
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT TRUMP
HEADING BACK HARD AGAINST
DEMOCRATS SAYING THEY WANT TO
TAKE AWAY YOUR GUNS.
HE'S REFUSING TO BACK DOWN AFTER
SAYING HE'LL CONFISCATE GUNS.
>> President Trump: LEFT-WING
DEMOCRATS WANT TO CONFISCATE
YOUR GUNS AND ELIMINATE YOUR
GOD-GIVEN RIGHT TO SELF-DEFENSE.
AS YOUR PRESIDENT, I WILL NEVER
ALLOW THEM TO TAKE AWAY YOUR
LIBERTY AND I WILL NEVER, EVER
SACRED RIGHT TO KEEP AND BEAR
ARMS.
>> Jesse: AND ANOTHER 2020
DEMOCRATIC TAKING THE CALLS.
HERE'S KAMALA HARRIS.
>> A BUYBACK PROGRAM IS A GOOD
IDEA.
NOW WE NEED TO DO IT THE RIGHT
WAY.
PART OF THAT HAS TO BE BUYBACK
AND GIVE PEOPLE THEIR VALUE, THE
FINANCIAL VALUE OF WHAT THEY
HAVE AND NOT JUST TAKE THINGS
FROM PEOPLE THAT HAVE VALUE
WITHOUT COMPENSATING THEM.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, SO JUAN,
FOR MANY, MANY YEARS,
REPUBLICANS HAVE SAID DEMOCRATS
ARE COMING FOR YOUR GUNS.
AND YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN SAYING,
OH, NO THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THAT'S JUST A TALKING POINT.
BUT NOW WE KNOW IT'S TRUE,
BECAUSE THEY ARE COMING FOR OUR
GUNS, SO WHAT IS IT LIKE TO BE
WRONG?
>> Juan: IT'S NOT TRUE.
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU MEAN
IT'S NOT TRUE?
HE'S SAID IT'S TRUE.
>> Juan: PLAY IT HOWEVER MANY
TIMES YOU WANT.
HE SAYS WE ARE COMING FOR
WEAPONS.
A BATTLEFIELD INTENDED TO KILL
AND MAIM.
>> Juan: THAT'S EVERY GUN EVER
MADE.
BUT HE DIDN'T SAY GUNS.
THERE'S A DISCONNECT WITH THE
POLITICIANS AT THAT         AT H
POLITICIANS AT THAT         AT S
POLITICIANS AT THAT         AT M
POLITICIANS AT THAT         AT N
POLITICIANS AT THAT         AT T
POLITICIANS AT THAT         AT .
>> Juan: SO, LOOK.
HERE'S MY THOUGHTS.
OBAMA COULDN'T DO ANYTHING.
BUSH COULDN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT
IT.
I THINK TRUMP HAS A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY.
HIS POSITION IN TERMS OF HIS
APPEAL AND ALL THAT AND THE FACT
THAT HE'S CLOSE TO THE NRA TO
ACTUALLY GET SOMETHING DONE.
HE SAYS THAT HE IS NOT GOING TO
PICK UP ON THE HOUSE, THE
DEMOCRATIC HOUSE PASSED BILL
THAT REQUIRES UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
BUT MR. TRUMP, IF YOU WOULD DO
THAT, I WILL SING YOUR PRAISES.
BUT WHAT HE DID ON CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM, HE DIDN'T GET IT
DONE.
I THINK THIS GUY COULD DO IT.
I'VE BEEN SAYING THAT FOREVER.
>> Jesse: SO WHAT ARE THE
BIPARTISAN IDEAS ON REDUCING
MASS SHOOTINGS THAT THE
PRESIDENT COULD POSSIBLY MOVE
FORWARD ON?
>> Greg: I TALKED ABOUT THE
CIVIL TAX SYSTEM, WHICH,
UNFORTUNATELY BETO O'ROURKE HAS
MESSED UP BY MAKING IT ABOUT HI
HIM.
THAT LEADS INTO THE FEARS OF
PEOPLE WHO OWN GUNS THAT A CIVIL
TAX OR A RED FLAG SYSTEM WILL BE
USED.
I WAS HOPING THAT THAT WHEN A
BEAD             WHEN IT
BE THE CASE.
WHAT BETO O'ROURKE IS SAYING
THAT I COULD JUST MAKE A PHONE
CALL AND YOU WOULD LOSE YOUR
GUN.
HE REALLY SCREWED UP A LOT OF
PROGRESS.
I ALSO THINK THAT THERE IS
PROGRESS TO BE MADE IN COSMETICS
THAT YOU PUT ONTO GUN THAT
AREN'T NECESSARY THAT TREND TO
ATTRACT A CERTAIN TYPE OF GUN
OWNER.
PEOPLE TEND TO DISAGREE WITH ME
ON THAT.
THAT'S OKAY.
WE CAN DISCUSS IT.
>> Juan: SERIOUSLY.
[LAUGHTER]
80 OR 90% OF PEOPLE SAY THAT
BACKGROUND CHECKS ARE COOL.
I THINK EVEN MOST REPUBLICANS
AND NRA MEMBERS SAY THAT ALL OF
THESE MAGAZINES, WE DON'T NEED.
WOULD YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> Greg: I JUST SAID.
I JUST TALKED ABOUT THE CIVIL
TAXES.
RECENTLY, I TALKED ABOUT THE
WHOLE IDEA OF THE COSMETIC
ADDITIONS TO THE GUNS THAT DON'T
CHANGE THE POWER OF THE GUN,
THAT MAY BE ATTRACT A CERTAIN
KIND OF USER.
>> Jesse: YEAH, BECAUSE THE
AR-15, YOU REALLY CAN'T HUNT
WITH THAT, BECAUSE YOU CAN
BARELY PUT DOWN ANYTHING.
IT'S NOT THAT POWERFUL OF A GUN,
BUT THEY MAKE MUCH MORE POWERFUL
RIFLES I COULD REALLY HURT
PEOPLE THAT THE DEMOCRATS DON'T
EVEN TALK ABOUT.
>> Dana: I THINK THE
WHITE HOUSE IS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY, WHAT COULD THEY
PROPOSE THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO
GET SOME BIPARTISAN SUPPORT?
IT IS A TRICKY THING.
I DO THINK, HOWEVER, I READ A
STORY TODAY THAT THE NRA WON'T
BE AS POWERFUL BECAUSE OF THE
TROUBLES THAT THEY'RE HAVING.
BUT THE THING IS THAT
BETO O'ROURKE AND KAMALA HARRIS
ARE DOING THAT WORK FOR THEM.
IT'S ALREADY GOING TO ENERGIZE
PEOPLE TO COME UP TO VOTE.
AND THEN THE PRESIDENT, HE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO FIND SOMETHING TO DO
ON BACKGROUND CHECKS, BUT THAT
WILL DEFINITELY BE IN THE
DETAILS.
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT HIGH-CAPACITY MAGAZINES?
YOU HAVE TEN IN OUR USUAL
WEAPON, AB 30    30 IN A HIGH-PO
WEAPON, AB 30    30 IN A HIGH-PE
WEAPON, AB 30    30 IN A HIGH-PR
RIFLE.
>> Emily: MAY BE.
I THINK THAT MIGHT BE A
REGULATION RATHER THAN MANDATORY
CONFISCATION.
IF I COULD FOCUS ON
KAMALA HARRIS FOR A SECOND, FOR
SOMEONE WHO HAS HAD DECADES OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE EXPERIENCE, I
FIND HER FLIP-FLOPPING VERY
CONFUSING.
SHE STARTED WITH THE TAKE BACK
AND NOW THE BUYBACK, WHICH MAKES
NO SENSE.
SHE BUILDS HERSELF UP AS A
"PROGRESSIVE PROSECUTOR."
BUT IT WAS A STATUS QUO.
UNDER HER REIGN, THERE WERE A
LOT OF ATROCITIES THAT HAPPENED
THAT NOW SHE HAS DISTANCED
HERSELF FROM.
THE SUPREME COURT SAID THAT YOUR
OVERCROWDING IN CALIFORNIA IS
CRUEL AND UNUSUAL.
SHE DEFENDED IT BY SAYING I
WASN'T BEHIND THIS.
I LITERALLY HAD NO IDEA.
I FIND THAT EITHER INADEQUATE OR
INCOMPETENT.
SO FOR ME COMING FROM CALIFORNIA
AND ALSO HAVING A CRIMINAL
JUSTICE BACKGROUND, THAT'S WHY I
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT HER JUMPING